Everybody.
Uh,
thanks for having me here.
I just want to say first of all,
uh,
I'm truly honored to be here.
This is a really cool to talk to somebody awesome smart people,
and it'd be at a company that I've watched,
um,
you know,
uh,
as a fan almost my whole adult life,
so I just really appreciate it.
My name is Aaron [inaudible].
I'm the founder of leaf technologies and I'm absolutely obsessed with
snowboarding.
There's just something about that movement and that feeling of snowboarding
that's just incredible and it's so incredible that you've got 39 million people
around the world spending $2 billion a year to enjoy it for only five days a
year on average,
just five days a year.
Would you play basketball five days a year or soccer or anything else for just
five days a year maybe.
But snowboarding,
it's really,
is that incredible?
It's that worth it.
But obviously we have a lot of the year we're on the sidelines just hanging out.
Now I know a lot of you might not be snowboarders.
So what I'm about to show you,
you might not grasp the full reality,
the full gravity of that.
So if you could just for a moment think about something that,
uh,
is a,
an activity that you can only enjoy five days a year.
Maybe it's traveling,
uh,
like a fishing trip maybe,
or climbing a mountain.
Think about,
think about that experience for a second and in those feelings that you have
enjoying this.
And now imagine if somebody told you you can enjoy this experience and have
these feelings on demand anywhere in the world after work on the weekends,
whenever you want.
That's basically what we've done for snowboarders.
And so,
uh,
what is it about snowboarding that makes it so incredible?
And it's,
it's a combination of speed and turning and carving,
which is,
uh,
you know,
leaning into your,
your,
your carbs,
your turns rather.
But it's,
it's this control drift.
I think that is really that,
that addicting part and the drift.
It's,
it's something that,
you know,
from the first time you ran and slid across your kitchen floor or drifted out
the back tire of your bike or your scooters,
a kid or you know,
doing donuts around your high school parking lot.
It's,
there's something just addicting about that.
And snowboarding is really unique because it takes that drift and put you in
total control.
And so you can spin and you can slide and there's really just nothing else like
it.
And uh,
and so,
so that is just,
just so unique to snowboarding.
It's something that has just never existed anywhere else.
Another great thing about snowboarding is that community aspect.
So sharing this adrenaline with your friends and uh,
and,
and going on and snowboarding with them.
And sometimes,
you know,
given that snowboarding is just a five day a year experience,
you might only see these friends five days a year,
or at least just enjoying this,
this experience with them for only five days.
And so all of these things together,
sobering can be a little bit of a frustrating sport most of the year.
And so that's what we set out to change.
And we are a group of snowboarders that all share that dream of writing all year
round.
And I can tell you getting to that point where we can enjoy this sport all year
round as a snowboarder,
it's,
it really is a dream come true.
And so what does it look like?
It's Kinda hard to describe in words.
Somebody actually IX snowboarding and Dubai are around the world.
So I'll just show you a quick video that will show the,
uh,
the,
capabilities of the leaf.
Ah,
so there's a lot of going on there,
but essentially you can,
you can just think of the leaf that we've taken the mechanics of snowboarding
and treated the potential energy that a mountain gives you mountain slope and
uh,
for the electronic,
mechanical energy of a electronic motors.
And so really the,
uh,
the key secret sauce to our system has this three 60 drive that you see here.
So this is really a caster wheel,
just like you see on the bottom of a shopping cart with a motor strapped to it
and a transmitting energy through a,
a slip ring and going into a battery pack and controlled by your hand.
And so those,
those drive wheels,
the base of it,
or a little bit lower to the ground and you can see in the tilting and drifting
part,
the outer edge wheels,
they function just like a snowboard.
So the edges on your snowboard,
and that's really there for just steering control and braking.
And the rest is you,
uh,
your,
your whole body controls this,
this crazy experience just like a snowboard.
And it's really almost magical if you know how to snowboard and you,
you take all of those,
that muscle memory and that experience and you jump on the,
the leaf and you can channel that through.
It just works.
In fact,
it only works if you write it just like a snowboard.
So how do you stop?
Very important question.
You stop just like a snowboard.
So sliding on your edge wheels,
just like you slide on the edge of a snowboard,
it's the most fun and most effective way of stopping.
You can go from our top speed of 23 miles an hour to a dead stop in less than
two car links,
which have you try that on,
you know,
a bike or something else.
You might,
you know,
go over the handlebars,
but you're leaning into that,
that slide in that force.
So you can stop really hard and be really comfortable.
So it gives you a lot of control when you're at top speed.
Okay.
And you might've noticed there's these,
these hooks that kind of fit over your feet,
and this adds a ton of control.
Just like a snowboard.
Now with a snowboard,
you're locked on,
and so you can't,
uh,
there's no safety bail out with the snowboard,
but just knowing to you,
so it's okay.
But when you're operating over Pavan,
you definitely want to have the ability to jump off.
And it's funny,
once you,
once you get rolling on the leaf for a while and you go back to snowboarding,
uh,
you're,
you're kind of weirdly freaked out by the way,
the ability,
you can't jump off.
So it kind of takes a couple of rounds to get back into it.
But that's a key feature and a,
a must for getting out of these footholds.
And so on the acceleration,
it's a wireless remote control.
And so you can think of this as kind of controlling your mountain slope.
And so if you have it all the way forward,
the gas pedal completely hammered down.
That's like a triple black diamond,
like dropping in,
just getting off super fast,
uh,
or you can just really lightly move the controller forward.
And it could be like a nice bunny hill slope.
But the nice thing is,
is that at any point in time,
if you get nervous,
uh,
if you get a little bit out of control,
you can let go and the motors will just coast and eventually we'll come to a
stop.
And so really it's a bit like snowboarding,
but you can make the mountain go away anytime you want.
And then we made the battery swappable because if you're a snowboarder,
even if you've never dreamed about snowboarding on city streets,
you've definitely dreamed about the endless slope because of some point you get
to the bottom of the mountain,
which is a total drag.
So you have to wait in line,
get in the lift up.
And so you always dream about that endless slope and we wanted that ability.
And so for us,
the endless slope is getting to the end of a battery,
not having to go home and charge it,
but rather just switch out another battery and keep going.
These batteries will go up to 15 miles and our largest size and so far I haven't
seen anybody go pass three batteries.
That's been kind of the human limit of finance at this point.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
So before I get into this part,
um,
uh,
this,
this project,
I mean from,
from the beginning,
I mean that the crux of this was figuring out that powered cast.
We all,
that was the thing that electronic engineers,
mechanical engineers,
investors,
friends and family all told us was it probably impossible.
Um,
but none of us are engineers.
So we didn't have that experience to kind of think it was impossible.
We just knew this had to happen.
We just knew that if,
if we could bring this experience to 365 days a year,
the,
the idea is just so big and such a big life improvement for snowboarders.
And so we just,
we didn't understand we had to make it happen.
And so,
um,
we,
we had to kind of go the bootstrapping route,
especially since we didn't have a lot of funding.
And,
um,
and again,
you know,
when we were pitching investors in the beginning trying to convince them,
the snowboard everywhere,
they just,
nobody would believe.
Even Kickstarter didn't believe.
In fact,
when we launched our Kickstarter,
they flagged us for spam because they thought it was fake.
And Luckily I was,
we built this in Brooklyn kickstarters in Brooklyn.
So when I got that email,
I was pretty annoyed because it was real.
So we just grabbed the board a road over to kickstarters headquarters and just
did laps in their lobby until they launched our campaign,
which only took about an hour.
But we got up and we're up and running.
But there were a number of lessons that we learned along the way.
Cause when we started this,
it was kind of early and a lot harder projects happening now,
but,
but a few years ago it was,
it was a kind of desperate and there wasn't like a,
uh,
a tutorial out there or even,
you know,
a roadmap on how to bootstrap hardware.
But we learned that we were able to do it and we learned a lot of lessons on the
way.
So I'll share those with you.
A number one,
youtube is the matrix.
And what I mean by that,
uh,
is my favorite part of the matrix wasn't like dodging bullets or flying.
It was like downloading skills to your brain.
You know,
instantly.
That was what I was most fascinated about it.
If I could take anything from the matrix and putting real life,
that's what I would pick.
And that's what youtube is in a way.
I mean,
I'm not an engineer.
I knew nothing about,
uh,
what we all,
all these,
this technology that we had to put together for this board.
And I remember it was like one lazy Thanksgiving afternoon,
everybody at Eaton and we're just kind of all laying around.
And I thought,
wow,
I'd really rather be snowboarding right now.
And I had an electric tape,
but at the time,
and I was thinking like this would just be so,
such a better experience of,
it would felt like snowboarding.
It would be game changing.
And so I started kind of thinking about those pieces of my electric skateboard
and start searching.
Okay.
Uh,
lithium ion batteries was a big feature.
I knew nothing.
What is the lithium out of battery and I found on Youtube,
but lecture from Carnegie Mellon,
90 minutes about lithium ion battery technology.
And that was four years ago.
Have we've actually gone through a lot,
built this product.
I know,
maybe 5% more than I did that day after watching that lecture.
And you know,
I watched it,
uh,
and as like kind of like a,
you know,
unplugged the matrix.
And I was like,
I know lithium ion batteries.
And then I was like,
okay,
how do I,
how do I go to the next piece?
How do you,
uh,
put electricity through a rotating circuit?
And it turns out there's these things called slip rings that I didn't even know
about.
And they're there in everything.
A headphone Jack in fact,
as a slip ring.
And so I saw a few videos on those and we kind of had to reinvent the ring a
little bit,
but the,
the,
the main idea was there,
I knew,
okay,
we've,
there's gotta be a slip ring,
there's gotta be a luck,
uh,
electronic batteries.
There's gotta be motors.
And,
you know,
in a lazy afternoon you can surprise,
I get a lot done on youtube if you spend it the right way of course.
But,
uh,
my biggest,
I guess advice to even engineers is if,
if you don't know anything about the technology,
there's probably a youtube video out there.
And you know,
even if it's some guy in his garage putting a tutorial,
sometimes those are the best ones.
Um,
next w we kind of came up with a way of doing PR and we call the downstairs
demo.
And so traditionally with Pr,
um,
it's a big part of,
of bootstrapping something because you don't have an ad budget and you probably
can't even hire a PR agent.
And so you've got to get,
you know,
organic articles out there that you weren't paying for.
And uh,
traditionally you know,
you,
you research your right,
the writers that you think you can that would be interested in what you're
doing.
You look at their interests,
the topics that they are,
they alike and how you can position your company and you write an awesome email
that you send at 10:00 AM on Tuesday to kind of catch them in between tasks.
But the problem is everybody is doing that.
You know,
they're getting thousands of emails at 10:00 AM on Tuesday and unfortunately
most likely won't get read.
And so you have to take it a step further and what we call the downstairs demo.
And the first step to that is find out where they work,
the address to where they work.
This is getting creepy,
but just hang in there with me for a second.
So you find out where they work.
Um,
and you show up maybe an hour before or after lunch,
maybe the last hour of the day.
And you get up to their lobby.
You're not going to get past the lobby,
but don't worry,
you don't have to get past the lobby.
You just take a,
you know,
your,
your smartphone and you film yourself using your device in their lobby or in
front of their building.
If they kick you out of the lobby or on the street,
if they make you get off the four Aa,
which has happened.
And in our case,
you know,
just doing donuts and saying,
hey look,
you're one short elevator ride away from trying this crazy new tech that got a
100% response rate.
Not everybody came down but half the people came down and all those people wrote
about us.
That's how we got in the verge,
in Gadget Gizmodo and a lot of big publications.
The other half of the people all said the exact same thing,
which is,
hey,
I've been burned by hardware startup,
a Kickstarter projects before and I just can't write about you.
And if you can figure that out before you show up to their lobby,
that'd be great.
But you know,
sometimes you just have to show up.
But that's a,
that's a big thing.
I mean we were lucky we were in New York and it was convenient,
but when we did this,
we did an one to two days and so quick trip to New York or la or wherever.
If you're not in these areas,
you can get a lot done.
Okay.
So on the prototyping side,
you're going to need a three d printer if you're prototyping hardware.
Because rapid prototyping is just,
uh,
it's not rapid.
You know,
you're talking one,
you know,
one to three days on the fastest turnaround time and it's incredibly expensive.
In fact,
on the first,
you know,
two models,
you might send a rapid prototyping,
you could actually buy a three d printer and once you make that one to $3,000
investment for a three d printer,
it's almost free.
And you can obviously iterate your,
uh,
your prototypes a lot faster by printing them at home because you are,
you have become essentially a rapid prototyper.
But there's ways to even speed it up beyond that.
So for example,
um,
so you've got a small motor mount that's part of your project and you've got
eight features that,
you know,
holes or things that fit into other things,
um,
as part of your project.
And you have to dial in each one at a time.
Now say this,
a little motor mount only takes an hour to print,
which is a pretty fast prep.
Okay.
You've got eight features.
Each one will say it takes two or three kind of prince to get it right.
That's 20 prints you have to make to dial in that one motor mountain.
Now that's still lightspeed compared to rapid prototyping.
You won't even get an email back from the company in 20 hours,
but you can go way faster.
And that is by printing in two d rather than three d.
And so if you've got that,
that motor mount and you're trying to dial in a hole,
you can actually just print a one millimeter layer face and you know,
peel it off,
get your calipers out,
measure it,
dial it in,
and you can print that one millimeter layer in two minutes.
So 20 prints instead of 20 hours,
you just turn it into 40 minutes of printing and that's how you can dial in
entire parts in an afternoon.
Um,
and that was a big,
big lesson kind of we learned along that way and you know,
look,
took literally days to kind of get all this stuff together and uh,
and,
and be on the road.
Uh,
definitely iterate with off the shelf components.
And this isn't anything a new idea,
but you definitely have to kind of think about,
um,
some of the constraints,
uh,
that might come with those off the shelf components.
And we had to deal with one in particular that was a little scary.
So our first version of this,
we basically took apart an electronic helicopter,
put the motors on a shopping cart wheel and put that onto a skateboard.
And a,
and we were often running.
And what we didn't realize though,
um,
is a feature of electronic helicopters,
which is great when you're,
when you're flying.
Um,
if you,
if you lose radio signal,
it'll go a full speed to stay in the air.
So I think you guys understand where I'm going with this.
We'd be riding around and in new city,
maybe the most dense place of 2.4 Gigahertz,
uh,
networks.
And when you lose signal,
you go full speed for a good,
like one to two seconds until it kind of gets back.
So it was kind of this mechanical bull that you had to be just ready to go full
speed at any given time.
And so we kind of learned what these parts,
okay.
You know,
we,
we learned these constraints.
And so a lot of the off the shelf parts you kind of have to read a lot more of
the directions then you might be prepared to,
uh,
before you get going.
Okay.
Um,
then the mobile labs,
so you definitely with hardware,
uh,
you're going to be doing a lot of field testing and in the beginning you're
going to be doing a lot more fixing than actually testing in the field.
And those,
those minutes that you know,
turned into hours and eventually turned into days of testing,
they're like gold in the beginning.
And you know,
when you're out in the field and something breaks,
which in the beginning will happen in the first two minutes,
uh,
you know,
you don't want to have to go back to the office,
45 minute train ride and go fix it and go back out to the field.
You need to take your mobile lab with you.
And so obviously there's like a lot of mechanical things that are built for
going with you,
like electronic drills,
wrenches,
things like that.
But eventually,
you know,
you're going to have to solder and soldering irons unfortunately take a lot of
current,
uh,
cause they have to get really hot.
And you all know,
I always have a plug with you especially,
um,
if you're,
you know,
going around New York City testing your product so you have to find plugs
around,
but they exist.
You know,
we've soldered,
um,
outside a public bathroom and central park.
Uh,
I've started in a coat closet at the plaza hotel.
They were nice enough to let me get in there and solder,
uh,
there,
they have these random plugs in the ceilings and the subway that you can,
you can dial into and get enough current to solder,
but just bring a whole lab with you.
Like don't,
don't think you have to go back and just,
you know,
carry everything around.
If you've got to drag a wagon with you,
it's really worth it.
Cause again,
it's going to be two minutes of testing and two hours of fixing in the
beginning.
Yeah.
And so,
um,
yeah I could go on on about hardware stories,
startups,
but I think maybe this is a good time that just switch it over to a Q and.
A.
And again,
I just really appreciate everybody coming out to your story and the invitation.
Thanks so much.
Gotcha.
No,
we have a question.
Cube.
Anybody?
Okay.
I'm going to try to.
Awesome Gum.
Um,
so the big difference I see,
um,
in terms of the,
between this and boring skateboarding is the terrible things you're doing to the
wheel.
Um,
so,
uh,
this was that you said that people go through three batteries,
which they don't have to take home and recharge.
How often does it have to replace the wheels?
Yeah,
good question.
So we're in skateboarding,
you'll have a couple of factors that go into your wheels.
Uh,
one is kind of rebound,
how,
how bouncy it is.
Another one's called durometer,
which is how hard it is.
And so they have durometers from like,
you know,
like jelly all the way to hard plastic and the escape of wheels fall somewhere
in between.
And so the harder durometer will last longer because it just resists that,
uh,
that abrasion a little bit better.
And also it slides better because a,
it's not gripping that pavement.
And so we use a bit harder derometer wheels.
Then probably the average skateboard would skateboard or we consider our wheels
a bit hard on that derometer side.
But again,
it kind of works with that sliding and it lasts a lot longer.
And also a key,
so you can tell a little bit in this,
in this image.
So the outside of the wheels are kind of getting dirty and they start to cone.
And so whenever you get too much where you just flip the wheel 180 degrees and
they start working on the other side and then you flip it again and you flip it
again and you might get six flips before you have to change the wheels.
When I had a,
it was a five mile round trip commute in Brooklyn,
a set of wheels when flipped regularly with last about six months.
This,
yeah.
Wow.
But when you're commuting,
you're not obviously doing a bunch of three sixties and things,
you know,
you've got places to be so
good even so.
Yeah,
you can,
you can make a set of wheels last very long time.
Uh,
so,
uh,
when you say you're going with a harder material,
um,
what's the,
what's kind of snow skinniness is,
does this correspond to,
is it like a prepared piece or morning,
somewhat frozen over or just these skip the braking performance?
You had looked pretty good.
So it feels,
if it looks like it feels like a pretty soft snow.
Yeah.
I would say the,
and the most ideal scenario,
which is a nice kind of broken and we all and super smooth,
uh,
it's really the pavement actually that kinda determines the feeling that more
than anything.
Um,
if you're on like a garage floor,
say like a really slick,
uh,
concrete,
it's,
it's not like ice,
but it's definitely like a really hard packed,
we'll say.
Uh,
but the best is kind of a,
a nice,
uh,
kind of blacktop,
like a,
like a fresh street that just feels like a nice groomer.
Like you've got the first group of run of the day and you're just just jetting
super fast.
Uh,
I'd say it's kind of more like that.
Nice.
Um,
this is really awesome.
Can you talk a little bit more about how you like eject from the board or how
the straps come off?
Like can you adjust to the,
the degree to which you're strapped in and then like how does the trigger word,
I didn't know it was two buttons in your video.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
straps first we,
where we go.
Okay,
here we go.
So Chris actually did that and told him,
I said,
okay,
you're going to have to catch a front edge
and Jen bail out.
Which if you do this on a snowboard,
there's no,
there's no turning back.
I mean you're going to,
you're going to go face down.
So,
uh,
we probably should have this in slow mo,
but more or less when you're to get out and eject really easily,
you,
the,
the footholds are kind of out from the edge.
So when you're riding,
you're putting outward pressure with your feet to really like hold in and,
and kind of maintain that position.
But to get out,
you just bring your feet together and if you bring your feet together you can
even jump forward.
But if you don't,
you know,
you can jump backwards or whatever.
But um,
yeah,
we're kind of trained.
And did you get a muscle memory after doing a couple of times and just like
hopping together and getting out and you can adjust the height and how tight it
is and things like that.
So you,
I ride a little bit looser cause I like to be able to jump out very easily.
And so,
um,
but you want that control.
You want to be able to really like press in because that's really going to give
you that board control
on the remote control.
So there's a trigger and a thumbwheel.
And that's really,
you can find that on most a wireless remote electronic redoubles because there's
the safety or dead man's switch,
which is,
which in our case is the trigger.
And then there's the thumb wheel,
which is the accelerator.
And there's kind of two schools of thought.
And as the skateboarding or electric skateboard communities kind of split down
the middle and it's just whether you have the dead man's switch on your thumb or
your forefinger and you have the,
the uh,
accelerator on your thumb or the four fingers.
So the other way of doing it is putting the detriments switch on your thumb.
And then the trigger kind of like,
you know,
the old little RC cars.
The reason we didn't go that route is because we do find that some people when
they crash,
they grip,
you know,
and you definitely don't want to go full speed.
And so,
um,
even in our case,
uh,
if you grip,
you're not going to,
you know,
likely move the thumb wheel forward.
But,
uh,
moving the thumb wheel backward,
we'll actually provide electronic braking,
which typically we only use if you're in like a tight space and you can't turn
sideways to break.
But,
um,
the slide,
I need a break.
I mean,
that's the most fun,
the most effective.
And it actually got us a about less than half the product insurance rate,
I say as a normal actor,
skateboard because,
uh,
with those breaks there,
they're all electronic and you can lose your base by losing the wireless signal,
breaking a belt,
um,
or,
uh,
going over 25 miles an hour at which there's too much momentum to stop you.
And so,
so that provides a lot of stability and safety.
Great.
Thanks.
Yeah,
and I have actually like dreamed about snowboarding to work and still working on
roads.
So yeah,
it's here.
If you could talk a little bit about your background,
what you were doing before you started this.
Sure.
Uh,
I actually,
uh,
I co founded a marketing agency with a couple of buddies,
when I was 24 years old.
And,
uh,
it was,
doing a lot of digital marketing,
a lot of Seo.
So Google is obviously very relevant to our daily lives in that agency.
And,
uh,
you know,
but I'm a lifelong snowboarder.
This is something,
you know,
that I,
I always dreamed of.
I actually had started a version of that company when I was in high school and,
uh,
my junior year I actually moved out of my parents' house and started just
snowboarding all the time and barely graduated.
But it was always,
uh,
I kind of,
my dream,
my dream thing,
cause I'm from Indiana originally and it's super flat,
but there's a lot of snow and I would only get to ride once a year.
And so dreaming about that,
um,
at the end of every snowboard trip,
just,
it's always been kind of in the back of my head.
But yeah,
I had a background of,
you know,
starting a,
a company before.
And so when on that Thanksgiving Day when,
when this,
this thing got in my head,
it just couldn't get out.
And so,
um,
eventually when,
when leave started growing and I needed more of my time,
I switched over full time,
uh,
from my agency to leave tech.
Can you
tell a bit how do you see,
uh,
the involvement that the next model or the next generation,
how do you see this product going even further?
Okay.
Yeah,
for sure.
Um,
I think that lithium ion battery technology is going to define a lot of the
direction because we've,
we've really nailed the experience in terms of,
uh,
that snowboarding feeling and I think that future products,
from us,
we'll,
we'll maybe get a little bit more dialed in on that.
I mean that,
that feature is really nice,
but I think it's more about just being lighter,
possibly being faster.
But I'm really just,
and getting the price down.
I think a kid,
it could help a bit and that'll come with volume as we,
as we grow.
But you know,
just really,
you know,
serving these 39 million snowboarders around the world.
That's,
that's our dream is just to,
to grow our beloved sport and,
and make it a year round a type initiative.
You just led into the question I've been holding ground.
Um,
so with,
with a skateboard,
I can see your point with putting the battery pack on the board because you
routinely to batch you take your feet off the board.
Um,
but with this,
when you're traveling,
strapped in,
you've got much less reason to keep you keep the battery back on the board.
Um,
so you could wear it.
and you just mentioned that the board is heavy.
How are you implying that the board with all the stuff on it is heavier than,
or you snowboard and pair of depressingly heavy boots?
Well,
actually it's about equal.
So because you have so much gear on when you're snowboarding,
so you through,
you know,
your boots,
your jacket,
your pants,
gloves and all these things in a pile with their snowboard.
I,
it's,
it's about the same weight.
And so,
you know,
we're still talking,
15,
16 pounds,
um,
on our smallest model.
But,
you know,
I mean the,
the,
the dream is to go even lighter if,
if you don't,
you're not living in New York or San Francisco,
you're probably not walking a lot with the board.
So,
uh,
it's not really an issue for most people just throw in the back of their car,
but we definitely want it to be lighter.
I mean,
that's just probably a better experience all around.
And you know,
I do believe that one day you'll buy a cell phone with all the energy you'll
ever need for it.
Um,
and so hopefully that'll happen at the same,
uh,
with our board as well.
So,
um,
I think the design of your straps is a really interesting,
and I was wondering if you've explored,
um,
so I have one of those surf style skateboards with the,
I don't know if you've seen these,
where the front trucks really turn a lot.
He has got a castle real kind of,
Oh,
well,
yeah,
yeah.
It pivots right?
That kind of thing.
It's made by a company,
a local company called Carver,
the one that I have.
And uh,
and I love it,
but you can't easily all you with that skateboard.
Um,
because it's a little bit unstable.
It occurs to me that like if,
if I had straps,
kind of like your straps,
I could probably jump up curbs without a problem with that.
And it might be an interesting thing to try.
I don't know that.
Have you,
when you were prototyping this stuff,
did you try it on,
on some more standard kind of,
uh,
skateboards?
Well,
they're a bit scary on a skateboard and I'll tell you why.
One,
it's kind of hard to push and then get back in.
But the second thing is,
I mean,
you can't slide and stop,
so you really,
really,
really don't want to be locked in.
I mean,
that's why we're the skateboard.
Electric skateboard has to be completely clean on the top so you can kind of
move around and get your stance.
But for us,
you know,
you're really fixed on the outside.
And so that ability to slide the stop,
I mean that's what the food was really help you with.
But on a skateboard,
um,
again,
it's,
it,
if you're not pushing then,
um,
you don't have to worry about moving back in to push though if you have it
electronic.
But again,
like,
uh,
it's,
it's a little scary just because you can't,
you can't slide and stop.
I see.
Yeah.
The,
the thing about pushing is like with,
with those special trucks that I was talking about,
you can,
you can basically,
you barely need to push,
you can just go side to side and Carlo the pumping the pump,
but,
but yeah,
I get the is the stopping part.
That's scary.
Yes.
How do you stop on this thing?
I mean,
I guess sometimes you can jump off,
uh,
you can do a power slide type thing.
Okay.
And then your wheels.
Yeah.
Maybe if you like got over that,
uh,
that caster and maybe you're able to slide,
get a lot of friction maybe.
But yeah,
I find them scary on almost anything else,
but yeah,
we have tried that.
You definitely want to be able to turn and stop.
Okay.
Has anyone ever done anything that you weren't expecting them to do?
What the board?
Um,
well I think that,
you know,
the,
the hardest part of this project,
it wasn't getting the thing invented actually that we did that in about five
months from,
you know,
just an empty desk with drawings to actually a thing on the ground that,
you could slide stopped up.
The hard part was getting it to something that a consumer is not going to break
in the first 10 minutes.
Um,
yeah,
I mean I think consumers will do like things with your product that you wouldn't
imagine.
Uh,
you know,
this is sitting on the,
the,
the motherboard for example.
Um,
but I think some of the,
the more surprising thing was just kind of how quickly a lot of people have
picked it up.
Um,
you know,
I think in my case it was a little different because I was writing,
put it as a gray constantly.
So I kind of took me forever to learn.
But seeing how quickly people jump on and just start sliding around.
I mean,
it just blows my mind sometimes and I'm like,
wow,
it took me hours to get to that point.
And there they literally just kind of jumped off.
But the,
the key thing was,
was dialing in the snowboard feel.
And so if you snowboard,
we actually have you close your eyes when we put you on the board for the first
time and we control the speed.
Uh,
and we,
you know,
we'd let you,
we hold the shoulder so you have a little bit stability.
But if you close your eyes and you imagine you're on the snow,
it just,
it just happens immediately.
Just magically.
Um,
but then when you open your eyes and you,
you know,
you see the pavement,
all these other things that Kinda make you nervous,
uh,
then you know,
you,
you've got to kind of learn to get over that.
But while we learned from doing a lot of demos is if somebody has snowberry
experience,
just blindfold them,
may their close your eyes do something because then they'll feel that in the
first 10 seconds.
And once they feel that slide because it really does feel like snow cause you're
kind of going sideways and like that just doesn't happen anywhere else.
Um,
then then they're hooked,
then they will,
they will go through and,
and fall or do anything to kind of have that,
that feeling again.
And so that was like a big thing we learned,
uh,
going on is like get a user and sliding as,
as quickly as possible.
So you were saying that it's pretty easy to learn if I don't know how to
snowboard,
but I don't know how to Skateboard,
you're actually better off.
Okay.
The,
in fact,
the best candidate that,
that we could ask for that it's never got on our board before is somebody that
has never skateboarded.
Cause there's certain things you have to unlearn from skateboarding.
If you ride this like a skateboard,
it just won't work.
It'll be super frustrated.
Um,
somebody was snowboarding experience obviously,
but also a surfer.
So if you can surf and snowboard,
you'll pick it up pretty quickly because surfing,
I mean,
learn that,
that middle balance point,
because you know,
learning to surf,
it feels like you're,
you're on ice,
it's just crazy.
But you really learned to kind of balance over.
And that's a key thing in the beginning because when we started people on the
board,
we don't put them under the footholds in the beginning because you know,
they've got to kind of learn how to bail off.
And so without those footholds to pull the board around,
you really have to maintain that center balance.
And we find that surfers a do really well at that.
So like people from Brazil just jump on the board and they're just like gone
there.
They pick it up really quickly.
How much is this board?
So,
uh,
the 10 mile model starts at 1549.
Okay.
And,
uh,
hopefully if you're watching this video in a few years,
it's a lot less.
Okay.
And the last question,
so I remember a while ago I saw this,
I don't know if this might be,
this is the same company freeboard basic.
Yes,
it looks like kind of looks like this does without the mater.
Yeah.
So really,
I mean we definitely invented a few things along the way,
but I mean,
uh,
at a high level we just took existing tech and just put it in,
combined it in different ways.
So,
um,
the freeboard plus the boosted you can kind of think of as her,
because I remember thinking exactly that like,
oh,
I wish it would just go and flood them.
So yeah,
no,
when I,
when I saw that for the first time,
um,
it was like,
I've never had a religious experience,
but when I saw that it was like,
it just,
it was,
it was incredible.
Uh,
but then I did some research and,
well,
you have to have a hill.
And I was living in Manhattan.
There's no hills.
Uh,
W I was even going to buy just to read in a parking garage,
but as a skateboard,
I know you get kids that kicked out of parking garages like instantly.
So,
uh,
I was kind of back to square one,
but,
uh,
you know,
when Bootsie came out and,
and they were the first to use the AC motors is really tiny motors and,
uh,
and I got one and I was like,
okay,
I,
I think it's possible now,
but again,
that,
you know,
putting strapping it to a caster wheel,
no one thought that was possible.
Absolutely.
Ciro nobody.
Uh,
so do you think people can use this to like a train for snowboarding?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Wants to snowboard but doesn't know how to do it yet.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
we definitely do what we want to be the gateway drug to snowboarding,
you know,
for people in areas that don't have snow.
And,
uh,
I love snowboarding so much and I just respect the sport so much that,
you know,
when we launched,
I felt inherently that this could make people better,
but I didn't want to,
uh,
make that claim up front saying,
this is gonna make you a better snowboarder.
But that is the feedback we're getting from our customers.
Uh,
especially people that have only been a couple times and they're really new to
the sport and they get the leaf.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
one of my favorites was a customer we have in Singapore that he had been on a
couple trips,
was just obsessed with the sport,
got our board,
he went up,
he went on a snowboarding trip with some buddies.
Um,
meanwhile bought our board and he got back to Singapore,
ruinous board for three weeks,
went on another snowboarding trip and a with the same bodies and they all were
like,
you,
you just had a whole season.
What happened?
Like,
you got way better.
And,
uh,
and,
and that's the thing.
I mean,
when you're snowboarding,
when you take into account lift lines and lifts and lunch and you know,
the first day you're going to be smoked and the first couple hours you might
only have of like real actual writing,
you know,
just a few hours a day.
And so,
you know,
if you can get out with the leaf,
uh,
and one battery will last you a few hours and you can charge that a couple of
times a day.
I mean,
you can get seasons of writing and literally weeks,
so,
so yeah,
we were really happy to see that it was actually improving people's writing.
And,
and when we were in New York,
we actually had somebody,
um,
it was as I or called us up and say,
Hey,
I've got to be at this,
uh,
the snowboard mountain to kind of do a customer meeting and ride with them.
And I do,
I don't know how to snowboard if I buy your board,
can I,
can I get up to speed and learn?
And,
uh,
I was like,
yeah,
I think so.
And we actually connected them with one of our,
uh,
pro writers in New York to kind of show them the ropes and a,
I don't know if it closes a deal,
but I'm,
but,
uh,
he was super happy and actually road,
so,
so yeah,
I can definitely get you into the sport.
Nope.
So when you,
Ollie,
do you try to land on the front wheels?
Because if you land on the motor,
is he my easily damages?
Um,
actually all the forests bypasses the motors.
So you actually want to land on your,
on your base flat.
Yeah.
I mean a more experienced writer can kind of land on an edge or something like
that,
but landing flat is really what you want to do and,
and yeah,
you're coming down on those casters.
But the way that the,
the mechanical system,
you might be able to tell if I could pause this,
it's animated Gif,
but um,
the motor is really just kind of hanging off a mount on the front and so all
that load is going straight through the wheel into the deck and you know,
through you and then back down.
But it kind of bypasses that motor.
Really.
The motor is just kind of hanging off and the only load on the motors,
the timing belt.
So it's built,
I mean,
uh,
we've done seven stair gaps,
which is,
you know,
maybe Yay high.
And uh,
and yeah,
it's,
it's so funny.
You just have to like channel that,
that,
that snowboarding feeling and that those mechanics,
if you,
if you approach it like something new,
it's super scary.
But if you,
if you're like,
oh,
this is,
you know,
just imagine the snow,
like channel your five year old self and like see the snow,
it,
it did just magically works.
It's crazy.
Okay.
So when you drop him down from seven stairs,
lands like power slide or more like a skateboard.
You can you in fact,
one of our writers is his name's slide jump slide.
These slides jumps and my hands on a slide.
But yeah,
that's,
it's a super challenging,
uh,
trick,
but,
but yeah,
it's,
it's definitely,
I mean,
that's like the great thing about snowboarding and our board is like,
there's this endless progression and endless styles and so,
so yeah,
you can land sideways if you really want to.
Okay,
cool.
Thanks.
Oh,
do we have,
okay,
you talked a little bit about the,
your industrial design process and you talk a lot about wanting to,
um,
uh,
to mirror the experience of snowboarding.
So how did you think about that when you were designing the board and
communicating the,
the visual design to a consumer that may not have seen the video?
For sure.
Um,
so for us,
you know,
to call this a,
I'm a snowboarder and if this didn't feel like stuff,
I have zero interest in it.
And so in the beginning,
that's kind of how we got our name.
So the Turing test of our board was being able to like falling leaf down the
street.
So that's the first move you learn on snow.
You're just kind of like falling leaf down the mountain.
And so our board had to do that.
Nothing else can,
can falling leaf down down a city street.
And so we just kept iterating and getting into where,
you know,
we had enough torque to do that.
You know,
in the beginning we were,
we were literally burning the coils of the motors,
but,
uh,
it takes a lot of Torque,
um,
uh,
powered caster wheel.
But in terms of the industrial design,
um,
honestly for the first version,
you can kind of tell for the generation of the person that designer that kind of
looks like a,
like an,
like a first nes or maybe the first playstation or something that's real,
edgy,
dark,
uh,
you know,
device.
But I think that,
you know,
when you see it and,
and,
and this,
this thing popping out of the middle,
I mean,
obviously you're not going to put your feet there,
but you know,
your feet are,
you,
you kind of have like a,
a notion of,
of,
of kind of how to stand on it,
just,
just nationally where that grip tape is and things.
But,
um,
yeah,
I think with,
with future versions it can be a little bit,
maybe more communicated like a snowboard.
Uh,
also the,
you can't really tell them this photo,
but there's,
uh,
it's,
it's just by directional.
There's technically no front to the board.
Um,
we,
we do have some traction control for beginners.
So we're,
we're sensing which direction the boards going and applying a power rela
relative to that,
that direction.
So if you,
you know,
if your switch,
you won't have like anti attraction control,
it's got a,
it's got to follow with you if you,
if you go the other way.
Um,
and I think that kind of helps too because when they get out of the box or you
know,
which way is forward,
but it doesn't matter.
It just,
it knows which way is forward.
But I think there's,
yeah,
the definitely design wise,
um,
we can pick up a lot more in the next version.
Uh,
one other unrelated question you that,
uh,
you,
you started up in,
in New York and you know,
this genre product immediately made me think of Casey Neistat,
who's a very popular youtuber that's so he's messing around with electric,
you know,
modes of transportation,
as has he tried this yet?
Uh,
uh,
you know,
it's funny.
We,
um,
he,
I don't think he's tried it.
We actually ran into them when we were Beta testing.
Uh,
it was like 10 degrees January in New York and there was nobody out except one
of our Beta writers,
which is actually my brother.
And,
um,
and he was testing,
uh,
along,
ubid in New York,
but there's like the freedom tower and there's this huge bike lane.
It's really nice and smooth and if it's 10 degrees out and nobody's on it.
So he was out there,
they're going.
And Casey was actually,
um,
you know how he rides his board and films himself and he came up on our,
uh,
on our bid writer and of course,
like he,
he threw this huge sign.
He's like,
Whoa,
what is that?
And he stopped him and um,
he actually put us on his daily blog that day.
And uh,
and yeah,
our site was just like,
I mean it was like 12,000 visitors in the first 20 minutes.
I have to re he posted that and all he did was just a floor.
Luckily by my brother had like one of our promo cards on them and just floated
that out there.
And we had a ton of traffic.
Um,
and he's a big snowboarder and he does this like street snowboarding thing where
he,
he takes like a,
I don't know,
I think it's like a water ski rope behind,
uh,
a car snowboards around.
So this is like a lot better for that than that.
But uh,
yeah,
he's,
he's kind of the perfect person.
I know that he's really involved with boosted,
so I'm not sure if he has much interest,
but,
um,
maybe
you said something about traction control and I was wondering if you could say a
few things about the hardware that's inside,
kind of controlling the motor is a little bit.
Yeah,
totally.
Uh,
so the trashing control is remarkably simple.
basically,
you know,
when you're,
when you're going around a turn in a car and you start to slide out the,
you know,
slow down those back.
We in kind of,
you know,
lessons that slide out a little bit.
And so what we do is basically the same exact thing.
We're just slowing down the back wheel.
But again,
without being,
you know,
a front end,
the back can kind of change.
And so all who basically we have just a set of positive magnets on one side set
of negative magnets on the other hall sensor.
And you know,
if it's a positive reading,
we know we're going this way.
If it's negative reading,
we know we're going that way.
And then,
um,
if that changes,
you just change the power going to each motor.
It happens in milliseconds and it's remarkably simple.
I just like literally one hall sensor.
Um,
and I actually the,
there's like an organization around,
um,
hall sensors and memes and sensors and,
and they,
they found out somehow we were using that.
And I went and I,
I did a presentation at one of their conferences and they're super excited until
they found out I only had one hall sensor in the board.
And there were,
I think a little disappointed they wanted us to buy more
because there were people with Mri machines with thousands of hall sensors and,
and so,
so yeah,
that's kind of unexpected and funny.
Hey,
I was just wondering,
have you guys thought at all about maybe this product and the context of how
like escape Bark might evolve?
Um,
and specifically I'm thinking about how skate jumps are very different.
Like a vert is very different than like a proper snowboard kicker,
you know,
the landing and how that works.
And is there any thought of like,
would this kind of a product work in that kind of environment?
Not just in like,
you know,
hitting stare gaps and rails but also more snowboard style jumps?
Yeah,
definitely.
So have you ever heard of a pump track?
So it's like these,
this little track that's got these bumps and if you're on a skateboard you can
kind of like pump and keep momentum going around.
We thought those would be great,
but the scale was just far too small as you know,
built for a little skateboard and with snowboarding,
you know,
you've got these massive runs that are like,
sometimes 10 lanes wide.
Right.
And you know,
carving across those,
I mean it's just,
you know,
it makes your whole day and so there is definitely like a larger scale that
needs to happen with that.
And with a skate park for me,
um,
I like more like flat transition.
So maybe we'll look more like a pyramid rather than like a quarter pipe.
I do find that that that curve,
at least for me,
me and my skills aren't good enough,
but it kind of freaks me out.
Um,
and you know,
I've never really tried that on a snowboard so I couldn't really tell you.
But what I do on snow and what I love doing on this board is,
is more like what would be great as like a pyramid that would be like the size
of this room with huge walls that,
you know,
kind of transition.
Those are super fun.
And I think that definitely some day there will be kind of a park men for these,
but I think it's going to be at a much larger scale just given kind of how
snowboarding works and the fun parts of that.
Cool.
Yeah.
And on that note,
actually we,
you know,
prospect park in Brooklyn,
I don't know if anybody's ever been there,
but,
um,
it's like a leaf resort.
It's incredible.
Um,
there is a,
a huge loop around the park that's like four to six lanes wide.
That's super fun to carve and,
and get up to speed.
But then there's always little pads in the middle.
And so it's,
it's,
it's very different experience,
you know,
traveling through these little pads and,
and going on the,
the big,
uh,
the big outer ring.
But you know,
that,
that's kind of fun to kind of experience with that.
But when we came to Los Angeles and you know,
we,
we wrote up Griffith Park,
which is one of our favorite runs.
I mean that was an even,
I had never like use the same product and had such a different experience.
Um,
you know,
being on literally the side of a mountain going up that hill,
uh,
to Griffith Park.
And so it's,
uh,
it was,
it just blew our minds.
It was way different.
And I think there's just so many different contexts you can enjoy this board,
but I think that bigger,
wider is really nice.
How easy is it to bring the board on a plane?
Yeah,
so we,
uh,
we designed the batteries so that they're,
they're compliant with Tsa regulations and so I usually carry on the board.
Um,
you always have to carry on the battery and the remote control,
since there's a battery inside,
you can check the board if you like.
Um,
I've actually carried on to boards.
They were super annoyed,
but they let me through with it.
Um,
and,
and yeah,
just fits in the overhead and a lot of our customers take them everywhere.
And that was,
you know,
a key feature we really had to have.
And,
and that's why you see our battery packs are actually two batteries because the
standard,
the watt hour limit,
we had to split the pack and we can get a lot more mileage and stay under that
limit.
Everybody ready to ride?
Cool.
Let's do it.
Pretty sure.